think as much about when and where that
you're going to have big conversations
than the what of what you're going to
say that might mean not springing a big
discussion on your partner as you are
brushing your teeth getting ready for
bed you have to make sure you're both
mentally in the right place to have the
big conversation
I have a friend Alex who tweeted
recently the reason you're stressed is
because you have decisions to make and
you're not making them how true do you
think that is
so true and by the way not making a
decision is in and of itself actually a
decision but decisions are stressful and
no one teaches us how to make them
properly so I absolutely agree with Alex
what do you think is wrong about
conventional decision-making wisdom
well conventional wisdom teaches us that
money and love are two separate things
and if you have to make a decision about
your career or if there are a lot of
dollar signs involved you should think
about that with your head and analyze it
run some numbers use a spreadsheet but
do not let emotion enter that decision
and on the other side that love and
relationships are decisions that are
meant to be made with your heart and
really
um not let your head mess with those
decisions and that's completely wrong
because any big decision has a component
of money and a component of love to it
and if you are ignoring one of those uh
big Realms you are missing part of the
picture you're more likely to make a
decision that you regret and you're
going about it all wrong
how do you try to operationalize or
formalize the use of the heart when it
comes to decision making that seems like
a an ineffable impossibility that poets
have been trying to describe for a very
long time how would you formalize
something like that
well the key is um to use something that
helps you bring in both elements of The
Head and the Heart or intuition some
people refer to it as rather than the
heart your gut
um and one of the ways that we do this
is to suggest a framework a process to
go through so that you're not left to
your own devices and kind of groping
about trying to make the best decision
you can but really following a
structured but flexible process so that
it lets you access both The Head and the
Heart in a way that kind of gives you a
road map that you can rely on
that's the five C's that you come up
with clarify communicate choices
check-in and consequences
clarify to me seems like not only is it
the first one but most people when it
comes to decisions decision making
having Clarity around it
what is it that you're actually trying
to decide what is it that we're even
looking at here that seems to be a very
big stumbling block
in your experience which of the five C's
or what are the other ones that are also
large and how can people get more
clarity around their decisions
well you're right that the first step is
very important because it sets the stage
for all the other steps and if you don't
have Clarity on what you're seeking
what's important to you uh you're going
to be hard-pressed to get to a decision
that you feel good about because you
don't know what you're seeking so that
is a really important one and it sounds
simple right just get clarify what's
important to you but the truth is that
there are so many influences that cloud
what we care about right you have family
members you might have friends you might
have a manager who is telling you what
you should care about and so the big
part of being successful in that first
step is untangling what you want from
all of those other influences and just
tuning in to what is important to you
yes this is one of my favorite blog
posts of all time it's written by a guy
called Kyle Ashen Rhoda he wrote it back
in 2017 now and it's called what do you
want to want and in it he talks about
the problem that I want a lot of the
time aren't ours they are societal Norms
they are the way that we've dealt with
past trauma their Paths of lease
resistance they are any one of a million
things and what he says is that you need
to program more deeply than that you
need to get down to the source code of
your desires and work out what you want
to want and I've always loved using that
as a an Insight because the things that
you want aren't necessarily the things
that you want to want they just they
come from all over the place so one one
consideration
when it comes to making decisions
planning for the future so on and so
forth optionality and uncertainty
especially in the modern world an
unlimited number of different routes
that we can go down
how do you account for the inevitable
unknown unknowns of the future when it
comes to making a decision with limited
information right now
so I think that gets at our fifth C
which is consequences and you're right
you can't know how everything is going
to play out but as humans we have a bias
very strong bias to focus only on the
short term we see what's closest in
front of us and so what is important is
to not just think of the short term but
try to play out your decision on the
medium term and the longer term so
thinking about those different time
Horizons will help you realize that even
if there is something you haven't
anticipated because there will
absolutely be something that you don't
anticipate that you have tricked your
mind to overcome that short-term bias
and start to see that sometimes things
can be you know lead to better better
outcomes in the longer term if you just
play them out and I'll I'll give you an
example which is my older son switched
schools this year he's in fourth grade
and he did not want to leave the school
that he had gone to from pre-k and we
were trying to explain to him that yes
even though this year is going to be
uncomfortable you're meeting new people
it's a new environment uh there was new
things to get used to you actually will
be able to go up to 8th grade in this
school so you won't have to change next
year you'll have a longer time to be
with your friends and you know it's hard
to get a nine-year-old to do a lot of
things let alone see many years into the
future but that's an example of how we
all think right we all just think of I
want to avoid the discomfort of doing
something in the short run but it
actually might lead to more comfort in
the long run
given that a lot of people have concerns
around the consequences of their
decisions and as we said at the very
start one of the reasons that you might
be stressed is because you have
decisions to make and you're not making
them I imagine that people can become so
mired in considering the consequences
that it actually encourages them or
discourages them from making decisions
it encourages this sort of
nihilism apathy fear anxiety around the
future
how do you suggest that someone
work out the consequences without
getting too stuck
well I am someone who is prone to
analysis paralysis so I I understand
that the lady that wrote the book about
decision making surely not but I've
learned how to overcome that and part of
it is to force myself to go through this
process right so where I might want to
linger in thinking about something from
all different angles and to kind of play
it out on you know micro time Horizons I
realize that that's actually not going
to get me closer to a better outcome
that sometimes you do need to decide and
by going through the process you give
yourself more confidence that you have
turned over the right rocks that you
have consulted the right people that you
have importantly communicated with the
others who are going to be affected by
the decision and then my co-author has
this phrase which she got from her
father which is you've done your best
Angels couldn't do better and so there
is some confidence and we've heard from
readers of the book that that they do
feel more confident making the decisions
knowing that they have gone through this
process that they've approached it the
best that they could and that even if
their the outcome goes sideways like it
sometimes does they couldn't have
anticipated that and they couldn't have
done better I think the consideration or
the feeling that you could have would
have should have seen whatever it was
that was going to happen probably not
only in the moment looking back uh
causes people to have regret but right
now also makes people concerned because
you can almost project forward the
future regret if you make a bad decision
you think oh God I don't have to deal
with the fact that I should have got
that job instead of this job and you go
well as we said at this time I had
Peterson on the show a few years ago and
he said uh you have to consider the
price that you pay for inaction because
people presume that inaction has no cost
it's like no no inaction is also a
choice choosing not to do you don't have
the choice to not do something
everything that you do even not doing
something is doing something thing so
we've got uh clarification we understand
why that's important and consequences so
we've bookended the uh the five C's uh
communication when it comes to that what
are your principles around effective
communication for decision making
well so often when we think of
communicating we think of talking and if
there is someone else who's going to be
affected by the decision we think about
a lot about what are we going to say to
that person how are we going to you know
convince them about our point of view if
they might have a different one but
really a huge part of communication and
good communication is listening and it's
about setting up the conditions for a
good conversation and so one thing that
I have really taken away from all the
research and the work we've done on the
book is to think as much about when and
where that you're going to have big
conversations than the what of what
you're going to say and so that might
mean not springing a big discussion
about if you're going to move on your
partner as you are brushing your teeth
getting ready for bed or you are trying
to get the kids out the door in the
morning it might mean actually making an
appointment with that person which can
seem weird if they're the person we you
see all the time but you have to make
sure you're both mentally in the right
place to have the big conversation and
so even just simply saying hey I have
something on my mind I'd love to speak
with you about can we think about a time
maybe this weekend that we can have that
conversation and then leave your house
leave the place that has all the
day-to-day stresses the dishes that are
in the sink the laundry that's not
folded go outside I mean my husband and
I have had a lot of luck going on Hikes
and talking about big decisions our kids
are running up ahead and we're in an
expansive state of mind because we see
you know beautiful scenery and we're
actually letting ourselves think
differently than when we're mired in the
day-to-day and those conditions and
really listening to the other person
when they share what they're thinking
are too often overlooked elements of the
communication step I think that's that's
a very good way to put it that it's not
just about what you say it's the setting
that you put it into what about choices
so choices is I love choices actually
because when we are faced with a big
decision we often focus on binaries so
we think about do I
um marry this person or I do I break up
with them do I go for the promotion or
do I quit this job
and the truth is that there are so many
options in between and that's where you
can get really creative and the choices
and the check-in step actually go hand
in hand because when you're really in
the thick of a decision you might
Overlook some of the options available
to you and so checking in with friends
and family and trusted resources allows
you to generate more options that get
you out of that tunnel vision that let
you see oh right I thought that I'll
give you an example from my own life to
get more space I need to move I need a
bigger house I need to you know find a
way to get a home office for example
which is something that I very much did
not have at the start of uh covet and
then you know needed
but what I found by checking in with
other people and seeing what solutions
they had creatively come up with is that
you can rent a space that is outside of
your home which is incidentally where I
do my best work and that would not come
with all of the hassle and the expense
of moving but would actually get me the
outcome of having additional space where
I can do my work and so that is a very
key element of generating additional
choices that you might not come up with
just in the moment when you are thinking
about a decision
is the main difference about decisions
regarding money and love that they're
just Grandeur that they have uh more
impact on our life or is there something
particularly special about them outside
of that
I like that way of putting it that they
have more impact on our life
they often are
um very personal right they're they're
uh they're not ones that other people
you might want other people to tell you
what to do but they're not ones that
other people can really
choose for you and have them uh have the
the be in the alignment with your core
values so they're very idiosyncratic
it's it's not like saying uh this
particular dish is the best pizza at
this Pizzeria you should get that
because I had that last time you go well
the difference the degrees of freedom
you're having pizza taste is probably
not as wide as it is in ideal
relationship or financial or marital
setup yes and they're and they're um
they have life-changing effects on us
and so if you have a piece of pizza that
somebody else recommends you know you
might have a a good meal or you know a
not so good meal if you didn't like that
piece of pizza but it's not really going
to affect your life and so the the fact
that your life's trajectory can actually
be altered by these decisions make them
higher stakes and when they are higher
Stakes then they are more daunting and
more
um can be more paralyzing
why do money concerns influence our love
decisions I thought I thought that we
should be marrying for love falling in
love you know why is there a financial
component to the person that we're going
to spend the rest of our life with
well because when you connect your life
with someone then their financial
decisions uh have an impact on you in a
very real sense of that debt collectors
can come after you that their debt
becomes your debt that their Wind Falls
and places that are community property
States become your windfalls and so not
only are there actual impacts to the
dollars but then your career is
powerfully influenced by the person who
you connect your life with and and
particularly if you want children very
particularly if you are in a
heterosexual relationship and you are
the the mom
um You Are by default by Society often
expected to do more of the caregiving
and if you do not have a partner who
sees eye to eye on sharing the to work
equally doesn't need to be split down
the middle but but really having a true
stake in caring for the loved ones that
you've committed to caring for that that
can have real implications on on women's
careers we've saw that during covid when
so many women stepped out of the
workforce millions of women to care for
children who were no longer able to be
in school and so there are really real
implications financially for
um for the person who you decide to
spend your life with
what sort of
assessment or decision criteria should
you go through when looking at settling
down with someone
and thinking right well I guess I'd
better or get the self-assessment tax
return out what do you what do you do I
mean it's not the most romantic thing
for a first date but certainly if you
are deciding to move in together I mean
even to to spend time with someone we go
through in our book big conversations
that you should have before you might
feel ready and this is something that
when I took my co-author's class I was
dating someone who I had been seeing for
less than a year and we were making
decisions about do we look for a job in
the same city after we graduate do we
live together if we end up in that same
city and you know it was awkward to have
those conversations we had you know
certainly would prefer to push them off
but talking about what does it mean to
us to
uh live together uh does that do we are
we doing that with the expectation of
getting engaged or not how would we
contribute to the rent I mean all of
those things actually forced us to have
these big conversations that number one
were enabled us to see that we were
compatible in ways that we
might not have known otherwise and
actually made us feel more close to each
other because we had had those
vulnerable conversations and shared what
we were hoping for our lives and careers
and and actually brought us closer and
so we outlined some of those
conversations in the book
um and and I would say you know I was
had certainly dated people before made
decisions about
um being you know moving in with people
before and not had those conversations
and I saw the difference in
really how having these types of big
discussions and using this shared these
those shared conversations to determine
you know okay is this person uh someone
who I think I want to spend my life with
just makes such a huge difference in
your confidence in that that
relationship is uh the right one and
that it's going in the right direction
that you want the same things in the
long term what are those sorts of
conversations or what are some of the
biggest and most important ones that
people should have at an uncomfortably
early stage
well certainly about your career
aspirations and so are you somebody who
you know what is your level of ambition
what type of
um career do you want what do you do you
want one that you're moving around all
the time are you expecting someone to be
picking up and moving with you when that
happens
um so that's a huge topic a topic of
children do you want them how many when
um
that's another huge topic
um the topic about money that we just
talked about so you know do you have
debt
um what do you spend uh Reckless amounts
of money on
um things that are you know seem
theoretical at first but then if you
just do decide to spend your life with
somebody actually have real implications
on you know if you're marrying someone
if you want to spend your life with
someone who always wants the latest
gadget and they're going to get the new
iPhone when it comes out and they're
going to get you know upgrade their car
every few years I mean that might mean
you can't take the vacations that might
be important to you right so those types
tease out the trade-offs and the
compromises that you might have to make
um talking about uh family and what that
means to you do you want to live near
them the where you want to live is a big
topic of conversation and certainly one
that with more and more remote work is
uh actually can create more Choice which
is not always such a good thing so
making sure you're on the same page with
a future partner about where you want to
live is it important to you to be in
your family
um do you want to be in a city do you
want to be in close to Nature all of
those things are important to talk about
I know that it might sound quite uh odd
to be discussing the wisdom in asking
some of the most basic questions that
are going to impact your compatibility
with a partner but it is rare to front
load those sorts of conversations early
in a relationship because people don't
want to come across as being too Keen
they don't want to scare the other
person away it's this big you know these
decisions inherently are difficult and
challenging and front loading them
deciding okay let's discuss many of them
or even all of them now just feels it
feels effortful and challenging and
scary but the alternative is to continue
down this path with somebody up until
the point at which you are further
invested and potentially so invested
that it you it's very difficult to turn
around or make a different decision and
now you're stuck having to make
trade-offs which is going to cause
conflict
um so yeah I mean
make sure that the person that you're
with has values and a life plan that
aligns with yours sounds kind of obvious
but is also I think it's pretty rare
it is rare and every year that my
co-author would teach her class on work
and family that our book is based on
she would have students who would email
her or write to her after the class and
say I just want to let you know thanks
to your class I've broken up with my
long-term partner and it was really
painful but I realized we did not want
the same things and the more that we you
know continue to be together the more I
would be compromising what I want and
she would write back and say you know
I'm I'm sorry for you know the pain that
this has caused you and congratulations
because that is a very brave and
courageous decision to go after what you
want and find someone who will support
you in what you want
have you considered the challenges in
the modern dating world with unlimited
Choice online dating and
Instagram and so on and so forth that's
a choice as well that's a decision too
how can people cut through these sorts
of unlimited Choice scenarios
well what I love is that there is
research on this uh one of my other
professors at Stanford who I studied
with Baba shiv has done research on the
effects of two types of choice one is uh
sequential Choice which is the type of
choice you have on the dating apps you
can always swipe and find someone else
and there is this Eternal Quest for the
best that helps you makes you think that
there's the perfect person is just you
know a one swipe away and I'll just you
know continue to date and find that
person versus what he calls simultaneous
Choice which is when you bound the
choice and he talks about he's from
India and so when he decided that he
wanted to find a partner and get married
he told his parents they presented three
different potential suitors uh he met
them at the similar time frame same few
months went on several dates with them
and found found the one that he felt he
clicked with the most fortunately she
also felt the same way they got married
and have been married for decades and he
has replicated the effects of
simultaneous Choice versus sequential
choice in other places and found that
people who identify
their best choice from a
a number of choices that they experience
simultaneously uh have are more
satisfied with the outcomes and so there
are ways even if you're not in an
arranged marriage situation to do the
same thing so comparing
um the person who is the most likely
candidate who you you know enjoy
spending time with the most to maybe the
the person who you feel was the best
candidate like the The Suitor you
enjoyed the most in your most recent
dating history that can be a way to kind
of
fake if you will the simultaneous choice
and and not just keep feeling like okay
well the next person is right around the
corner because
um you're right that that Paradox of
choice we've seen does not lead to
happiness and it can lead to a lot of
frustration actually what
if you're already in relationship and
you're considering getting married what
are the things to consider before you
decide to take that step is there
anything unique that we haven't covered
already
uh well I think a big part of getting
married is formally legally tying
yourself to someone and your finances
and so one of the things we talk about
is prenups because prenuptial Agreements
are on the rise we have a lot of people
who grew up uh for example with divorced
parents
um that are seeing you know the
consequences of that on their own
family's finances people are getting
married later and so they're more likely
to have a lot of assets and or a lot of
debt and so it's very important to
um we don't think it's important to have
a prenup necessarily but to go through
the same conversations and have the same
discussions you would have if you were
setting one up which include disclosing
all of your debt and being financially
transparent with one another talking
about
um
the the assets that you have talking
about what's important to you
financially and you can do that
certainly formally with the support of
attorneys or you could do that uh
informally with one another maybe even
with a facilitator like a therapist or a
financial coach and we we did a survey
as part of our book and as part of the
research we heard from a number of
people who said we actually went through
the steps of uh having those
conversations didn't go so far as to
drop a legal document but feel like we
got the The Best of Both Worlds because
we now are going into this marriage with
our eyes wide open and I like to say
that a wedding is actually a microcosm
of all of the issues that you face uh as
a couple and so you you have to agree on
the role of religion and spirituality in
the day you have to agree on family and
how much influence uh financially and
otherwise you want them to have on your
day to think about the people who are
important to you and make decisions
about
um whether the day is really about you
or about them and so if you can survive
that planning process
um and come out you know on the other
side with an experience that is
Meaningful uh you are you are likely uh
to be well set up but the challenge is
that most many couples really focus on
that day at the expense of the rest of
their lives and we know a day is over
very quickly and so the more that you
can have those conversations leading up
to marriage about what you want in the
long run what's most important to you
how the other person can support you in
those goals the better off that you're
able to be are you saying discuss the
prenup as you're going down the aisle is
that the best approach for it uh no
ideally you would have those discussions
far before you walked on the aisle okay
if you say so I mean this is a very
unromantic unsexy part of romance right
like I have a number friends that are
married and all of them have had
discussions like this one of them
uh had a
contentious discussion with his partner
about prenup and lack thereof that they
were going to go in with and it's
difficult it's it's it's a concern with
um uh finding a partner who happens to
match you in terms of your financial
resources and financial future is is
rare and then people have got concerns
about divorces happening but then it
also if there is a disparity in terms of
either
resources now or wealth potential in the
future it kind of feels a little bit
like someone's already got one foot out
of the door it could be interpreted in
that sort of way so it's just a messy a
very very messy messy decision uh and
one that I haven't
I haven't considered about the nuts and
bolts of of what that looks like but
yeah it doesn't surprise me that it
probably takes a number of hours many
many hours to discuss okay so how are we
actually going to do this
well
it's messy but I would argue that going
into a relationship and a marriage
without those conversations is really uh
has the potential to be a lot Messier
because
um you really it is much better to get
all of that out in the open and be
transparent before you've made promises
to one another than it is on the other
side of it and you know I am now at the
age where I have friends uh who are
getting divorced sometimes after several
decades of marriage and
um it is it is that is a lot Messier
let's just put it that way I get you uh
what about before having kids what costs
should people think about before they
have children
well the cost that so many people are
shocked to see it's it's less of a shock
I think these days because it actually
has been in the news more
um with with covet and the the lack of
our infrastructure being uh revealed is
child care and often people uh don't
realize how much it costs to raise a
child which uh the estimates are about
half a million dollars
um up through uh age 18 and certainly
more than that when you talk on College
um but the early years are where a lot
of the um it can feel as if your entire
paycheck is going to pay to someone to
help care for your child when you're at
work and the math that I think is so
tricky is that often people deduct those
child care costs from again in a
heterosexual couple the woman's paycheck
and they say okay if you're you know not
making if you're making either are the
same as it costs to have a nanny or less
than that then it's just not worth it
and the truth is that that's really
flawed math one of the things that my
co-author taught in her class is no no
you add the paychecks together you
deduct the child care from The Joint
paycheck because it is actually a
long-term investment in the careers of
both of you so that you nobody has to
pause their career if they don't want to
to care for a child because it is a lot
harder to go back into the workforce if
you if you take a pause and you know
that you will not need a nanny forever
what what you don't realize though is
that schools close for the summer they
get out at 3 P.M and so you will likely
need some form of child care summer
camps after school programs for a very
long time certainly in La until your
children can take care of themselves and
so just going in with your eyes wide
open to all of the costs how you're
going to approach it how you both want
your child to be cared for some people
feel very strongly that they only want
family members to care for their
children whereas other people would
rather have a very large Village and if
they don't happen to live near their
family they're willing to pay for it and
so getting on the same page about your
approach your feelings about child care
your feelings about how you want your
careers to go actually how you'll divide
the work and this is it sounds so
mundane and boring compared to the idea
of bringing in a new life to the world
but frankly like who's going to wash the
bottles and who's going to prepare the
food and pack the lunches is where it
breaks down for a lot of couples and so
making sure that you have a plan and
you've discussed how it's all going to
shake out in terms of responsibility can
be very important and that's we have an
exercise in the book where you go
through and look at all of the different
tasks required to take care of a
household and take care of a child and
talk about are you you know who in a in
a again and a couple you have three
choices you have well I guess you have
four choices you have you know person a
can do it that person B could do it you
have you could Outsource it or I guess
you could just not do it and just you
know have a messy house and I mean you
can't not care for a child but there are
some tasks you can cross off
um and so going through and you know my
husband and I used to be guest speakers
in my co-authors class for over for
about a decade and we would joke uh that
we were making the drive it's about 45
minutes from San Francisco to Palo Alto
we would check in with each other about
how our division of labor was going at
home because we were about to get in
front of a class and air our Dirty
Laundry to the whole class and you know
better if something's not you know
working for you tell me now so that we
don't complain about it in front of the
class and that was actually we joked
about it but it was helpful because
there were some things where we realized
oh like I'm really sick of doing this
and I really wish you could you know
would you be willing to take this on and
you know one of those things with thank
you notes like I I wish I didn't care
about thank you notes but I do and so I
supervise my children writing thank you
notes for a really long time but at some
point I would rather like poke my eye
out with the pen that they were using
then you know help them write the thank
you notes and so thankfully my husband
agreed okay I will take over the thank
you note job and um how many thank you
notes are they producing I mean you
would be surprised if you have a class
of 25 kids and you know you're getting a
lot of birthday presents
it's more thank you notes than you want
okay I I I'm not going to argue with you
what is your advice for people who might
be in relationships that are less uh
communicatively transparent than yours
is it seems like you and your partner
have a
um
a lot of openness with regards to this
perhaps unsurprising given how you met
um
broaching these sorts of subjects
especially consistently
can cause friction you're always nagging
me or bugging me about this thing
there's always a new problem here
there's always a new
what are some of your pieces of advice
for people that are in relationships to
bring up issues and challenges in a way
which
is engenders the sort of response that
they're looking for which is one that's
collaborative
well a lot of that goes back to
the setting and so are you just bringing
this on on your partner when they're
watching their favorite TV show are you
you know uh
having it we actually recommend and this
is a practice that we've been doing I've
been doing for a while having a weekly
check-in
um we call it uh tcob taking care of
business where we just have it on the
calendar and I mean it's
not the most romantic thing but you just
you know have half an hour and we go
through the calendar for that week we
say you know who's doing pick up and
drop off it's our opportunity to kind of
bring up other things like right now
we're planning a trip and we were
looking at Airbnb listings uh on on in
that time and so if there's something on
the calendar you don't have to
constantly feel like you have to nag and
bring up it's just like it's on the
calendar we do it on you know Friday
afternoons and that's the time so this
the very small step I would suggest for
a couple who is like how do I break out
of this rut of one person constantly
bugging the other person just say hey
can we set a time every week to just
check in on you know the mundane tasks
that we have to take care of by nature
of being in a household together being
in a relationship together and you can
set it whatever time you want you can
make it really fun I know a couple that
goes out for drink thanks on Friday and
talks about it personally when I go out
for drinks I do not want to talk about
who's doing pickup and drop off so our
preference is to you know have a
different approach but you can tailor it
to you and um you can just try it you
could say hey I was listening to this
podcast and this author was on talking
about having a weekly meeting where you
talk about all the boring stuff involved
in running a household together and once
that meeting's on the calendar it's more
likely to happen nobody has to bring it
up and have an agenda and just go
through it and
um you could even have a walking meeting
I mean again it's up to the person's you
know everyone's preference but uh
certainly to have a um a neutral setting
and a neutral way so that it's not just
the same person bringing it up over and
over again can go a long way
I like the idea of creating a bucket in
which all of the things that need to be
discussed can be discussed I think that
you're going through your day you're in
the car with your partner you've you've
just been talking about that recent
movie that you watched that you both
loved or the last of us or whatever the
song that just came on on the radio or
reflection about when you went to go and
see your parents last year and it was a
catastrophe or whatever and then
somebody brings up
admin right one of these taking care of
business decisions and it it seems to
cross the boundary between the personal
and the organizational in a little bit
of a way and I wonder whether bundling
it all together it's like it's like I I
you not taking care of the thank you
notes isn't a comment on your worth as
an individual or my value in you as a
partner
but it is something that we need to
discuss so maybe I don't bring it up
just after we've been talking about
stuff that's a little bit more
touchy-feely and makes me feel nice
about the song on the radio or the last
of us or whatever so I think that's a
very very good solution actually one one
thing you mentioned
um regrets earlier on and challenges
what
is the most common life decision regret
that you've witnessed in your research
not doing things not taking risks not uh
trying something that you have always
wanted to so people don't regret
um
working too hard they do or they don't
regret um you know I didn't spend enough
time at the office I mean people regret
not spending time with people they love
and not taking risks not going for
um the big move or not um
trying something even if they didn't
know if this was going to succeed and
that's something that we've we've all
experienced over the last three years
where our choices got really narrowed
right there were places we couldn't
visit there were people we couldn't see
there were a lot of things that we
couldn't do and I think what we're
seeing in this current time were many of
those restrictions have been removed is
people making those choices to visit the
place that they always wanted to see or
to move closer to the person who they
couldn't see when they lived half a
world away and no planes were taking off
right so that is certainly a big part of
what the research says is that the res
the regret of not doing the thing
why do you think that is what do you
think that says about us psychologically
adaptively as humans
humans we
are
daunted by the unknown uh
but we love possibility we love the idea
that we could uh publish a book that we
could
um
spend time with the person who we really
care about but only if we take that leap
right and so yes you might not know how
things are going to go but that's not a
reason not to do something and so part
of what our framework offers is uh the
ability to again make sure you have done
your homework have have stepped through
all the steps to get out of the
emotional way of making a decision that
again might lead to regret I'm not doing
this because I'm scared I'm not doing
this because
um I I don't know how it's going to work
out but I'm pushing past that and
tapping into the things that could give
you more confidence not about how it's
going to work out but that you
approached it in a way that is valid
that is
proven to be effective and likely to
leave you feeling more confident and
empowered yeah it's it's so interesting
to consider that the things we regret
are not the things that we did but the
things that we didn't do
and
I don't know it makes me think that we
just over egg our
risk aversion conservative nature a
little bit but everyone's concern is
okay so maybe I can kind of just like a
sniper does I'll just adjust my sights
I'll just tune down my risk aversion by
10 or 20 that'll get me about there but
then you go oh yeah but what what if
it's on a just a category of decision to
which I shouldn't have done that and
then so
um yeah I think
if there is ever something reassuring
that everybody could learn
about the nature of decision making
in life's big decisions and about the
concern that they have about regrets for
the few in the future of things that
they haven't done in right now it is
precisely that it's the fact that people
end up regretting the stuff that they
didn't do and there's also some evidence
that I'd seen that suggests people that
make big life decisions generally on
average end up to be happier that it
just just by making a big change that
they end up being in a happier place I
wonder whether that satisfies just a bit
of novelty seeking perhaps that people
have you know objectively it could be a
slightly worse town but subjectively the
fact that it's somewhere new and there's
all of these different people and stuff
for you and also you're framing around
the present moment largely determines
your experience of it in any case so if
it is an adventure you can pick yourself
up by your bootstraps there uh one other
side of this I suppose the Dark Side of
marriage is if it needs to finish or the
dark side of a relationship as if it
needs to
split up
what's the process for working out
whether or not you should get divorced
or break up with a partner
I recently heard the term complete a
relationship which I thought was a nice
term no no that's no that's that makes
it sound like that's what everybody is
working towards it's true it's maybe not
the aspiration but it is a a Kinder way
of speaking about it well my co-author
has been divorced and she talks a lot
about
uh the importance of an amicable divorce
and certainly if there are children
involved
you can
um get to the point where you you know
maybe are not seeing eye to eye with the
person who you have decided to spend
your life with anymore and by the way we
are big Believers in therapy so working
with a trained professional sometimes
when you're just two people and it's you
know one person against the other person
um it's hard to break out of that
Dynamic and so bringing in someone else
who can say you know yes you can work
through these issues or know I see these
as really intractable problems that are
going to be very challenging that can be
very helpful
um that was something that my co-author
did in in her marriage our first
marriage and
um you know the therapist thought no
this this isn't actually a marriage that
I think uh is going to be able to be
resuscitated and so they did part ways
but they also did that very deliberately
wanting to not have their children
because they had to at the time be put
in a position of having to choose you
know which parent they're going to take
sides of and so they they had an
amicable divorce and actually when my
co-author got remarried
her new husband said you know what do
you think about inviting her ex-husband
who who he also knew to Thanksgiving and
she said are you kidding no why would I
want to do that he said well you know
otherwise your kids are going to have to
have two thanksgivings or not see one of
their parents on thanksgivings and she
said ask me again in five years and so
he was a patient person he asked again
and in five years she said okay let's
give it a try they all had Thanksgiving
together and it actually went so well
that at the end of the meal her
ex-husband and who was now remarried
they toasted uh the uh his ex-wife and
he said thank you so much for inviting
us to do this this was so meaningful and
they continued doing it for decades and
so it is possible to get to a point even
if you no longer want to spend your life
with someone to have shared experiences
that that are big sure and bigger than
the two of you that allow their children
in that particular instance to uh to
have both of their parents together on a
meaningful day
what do you think would predict a less
amicable divorce if you were to design
a um way for the partners to communicate
with each other the sort of things they
would say the way that the divorce would
be enacted what would you do if you
wanted to cause the worst divorce
possible
try to win
what do you mean
so uh try to exact the most money from
the person try to get everything on your
terms try to not agree to anything that
they want try to not compromise so if
you are trying to not have an amicable
divorce really seeing it as a one-time
negotiation right where you are more
likely to just try to get your way at
all costs
um if you're if you've clarified what's
important to you and if that Clarity has
told you what's important to me is
having an amicable relationship with
this person so I'm not constantly
pitting myself against them or making my
children if we have them choose then you
might agree to some things that are not
ideal so
um an example a story that I I heard is
um a woman and her husband got divorced
they had a teenage son and she knew that
if she uh stayed in the house with her
son it would be unlikely that he would
see his father that often um his father
was uh just not some not a big planner
um that was part of the challenge
and she said you know it's more
important to me that he has a strong
relationship that my son has a strong
relationship with his father than it is
for me to stay and live in the house
with them so she was the one that moved
out she you know continued to visit she
spent time with him but they it ended up
that he her son had a much closer
relationship with his father as a result
of their living arrangements than he
would have if she hadn't made that
concession and she feels you know she
gave up five years of of being able to
live with her son but it was for the
greater good of his relationship with
his dad
that's a very selfless act to do that
and I imagine that
as somebody approaches the end of a
divorce which is you know by
by its nature not exactly a paradise to
get through
there will be
resentment and and unanswered questions
and that thing that you did that I
couldn't stand you doing anymore uh so
for somebody to be such a the bigger
person or a more noble person at least
and do that I think is
uh a pretty good sign maybe he's like a
good one go with regards to that when it
comes to choosing where to live
whether this is you moving with a
partner or not I recently made the move
from the UK to Austin Texas and that was
something that had been on my mind for a
long time do I want to be here in the
northeast of the UK it's this place that
I was born in and I've always wanted to
travel somewhere else but it was a very
difficult decision to make I had to let
go of a lot of things I would have to
sell this business that I'd spent a
decade and a half building with my best
friend who owns the groomsome at his
wedding and sat next to him my first
ever seminar at University and I'm going
to lose my sense of identity I was this
big name on campus club promoter guy in
Newcastle and it was a relatively small
City and I'm gonna go to this brand new
country where I don't know anybody
basically and see if I can do this
talking to people on the internet thing
and make a career out of that
um
what what should I have done that would
have made the decision about whether or
not I should move uh more simple and
easy for me
well congratulations because you will
not have the regret of never making that
move and seeing how it would be if you
um had moved to Austin
one of the things I hope you did before
you moved was visit
um yeah
um and sometimes even you know renting a
place for a month right and and did
exactly that airbn beat it yeah and so
you get a sense of okay if I'm not just
swooping in on a weekend and having all
this fun but actually approximating the
life I would have if I lived here like
I'm gonna have to do laundry I'm gonna
have to go to the grocery store I'm
going to have to you know experience the
like not fun parts of living someplace
oh so you're offsetting the holiday
effect yes exactly
um so try to I mean this is in design
thinking um it's called prototyping
right so you're trying to prototype what
your life would be if you lived in
Austin so you are
um spending more time there than just a
weekend you can talk to people who made
similar moves to
either that specific City I mean it's
obviously most helpful but I mean
there's a lot of people who've been
moving to Austin recently um and so
getting a chance to talk to them about
what they like what they don't like what
they wish they had known before they
joined that Community can be very
helpful
um and you know so these are parts of
our framework right so
um the this is the check-in part uh
talking to people trying to approximate
it
um and then you know playing out the
consequences so uh you know that the
first part of living somewhere there
will be a lot of novelty you'll be
disoriented but it'll be fun and new
um but you know what are the places that
um what are the things that in the
medium term might be hard what might be
easy what might go wrong what might go
really right
um so playing out as many of those
scenarios as possible so that you start
to get a sense of uh of of do the kind
of positives the potential things that
could go right outweigh the things might
be hard or uncomfortable in the in those
different time Horizons
I did some of those I did I I stumbled
upon a number of those so I feel uh
Vindicated that I didn't make the
decision like a total idiot but yeah I
think the um
that is definitely a very very smart
idea if you are looking to move
somewhere to try and just test what's
life going to be like where can I go and
get my haircut how about the traffic
what's the weather like in the middle of
I mean I couldn't test what the weather
was like in the middle of summer and
there was 60 days where it didn't drop
below 100 last year but that's it
I'll take that that's a price that I'm
prepared to pay at one other thing that
you spoke about that I've never really
heard anybody talk about is elder care
uh as you get toward the end of life
what's what are the insights around that
well it's one of the so Myra's class my
co-author's class had a
um a class on it and there was a speaker
who came in and talked about different
types of elder care what are different
options and I took notes but I tuned it
out right it just seemed like something
I wouldn't have to think about for
decades and then as it turns out as life
would have it my mother had a very bad
accident she fell and hit her head and
had brain swelling and Trauma and I had
to think about these things much earlier
than I had anticipated and so I actually
got out the notes from the course and a
lot of it is the research that we talk
about in our chapter on Elder Care
um thinking about how to have these
conversations with our parents or other
uh Elder relatives that we might be
having them with the key a key is to
tread lightly it is these are very
tricky conversations they are
uncomfortable
um for you and likely for that other
person and so doing it with respect with
Grace trying to understand what's
important to the other person as well as
what's important to you and um certainly
checking in with other people one of the
things that I did when when my parents
they actually ended up moving out across
the country to where I lived in
California when my mom
um
needed more care and then they lived in
a condo and they had home health aids
but then they needed then my mom needed
more care then those aides were able to
provide and so I asked my father if he
had thought about life plan communities
which are communities that have an
element of Independent Living an element
of skilled of element of assisted living
and then an element of skilled nursing
and so at that point my mom needed the
skilled nursing my dad would have been
in independent living and he said you
know I haven't looked at any of those I
don't think we could afford it and I
said well I think you know let's just
tour a couple of them we'll ask some
questions we'll do some math and it
turned out that
um they they found one that accepted my
mother's insurance and
um and so having me as someone else who
was part of the conversation but not in
the decision myself was very helpful to
my father at that time and he it turns
out there have been a number of my
friends parents who have moved into the
same Community where he lives today
because he's had such a positive
experience there and so I have ended up
being a bit of a guide for a lot of
friends who faced this uh Crossroads
later than I did and and understanding
people's experiences can be so helpful
when you're facing those same uh same
choices
what are the main kinds of aldica
um well so if you have say your loved
one wants to remain in their home as
long as possible you can hire people to
come into that home they're called home
health aids or there are other other
folks who can are trained in how to care
for elders but sometimes I mean that's
very expensive and so and there's a
shortage of care workers as there is
across the board in so many of these
industries and so there are also these
communities where you can go and and
have rooms um they're almost like dorms
for older adults and lots of activities
and other
um other elements of a Vibrant Community
um but they're also expensive I mean and
and so having one of the things we talk
about in the book is long-term care
insurance because very few States offer
that Washington state is one of the few
States that have passed laws that
actually you're paying into long-term
care insurance by virtue of living in
that state but in other places it is
largely up to the individual there is
um health insurance available for older
people through Medicare and Medicaid but
it is very
um does not cover a lot of that
long-term care
um and yeah it's a it's very interesting
I have a friend whose dad was very ill
but very rich and uh they had this
really difficult situation with
inheritance because in the UK the way
that it works if you gift your children
I think it's 350 000 pounds is the upper
bound limit
anything over that you get taxed at some
ungodly percentage if you pass away
within the space of seven years and this
father had spent his entire career
building up a very large portfolio of
businesses and he was a super driven guy
and still had a lot of self-pride and
stuff like that uh and it was because I
mean the way that he got ill was kind of
out of nowhere so how he's supposed to
predict that sort of stuff
but I was about to say there's no such
thing as too early of a time to have
this discussion but if your parents are
still pretty independent you go hey Mum
and Dad how do you feel about me
chatting about you becoming older and
maybe needing help from professional
help from people
me thinking about me is that the sort of
thing oh is that what my children think
of me my children think that I I can't
take care of myself or that I'm going to
I'm going to kick the bucket soon that
also doesn't feel
like an easy conversation to have
there's difficult conversations
everywhere
there are there it is a very difficult
conversation but I would argue that it
is easier when you don't need to make
those decisions imminently and so if
you're saying I mean I always say blame
it on the book right just say I read
this new book it's called money and love
there's a chapter on Elder Care and it
talks about having these conversations
earlier than you want to which is by the
way never we never want to think about
our loved ones becoming you know unable
to take care of themselves and the truth
is that at some point everyone's loved
ones
um will either
die or become unable to take care of
themselves and so this is one of those
places where just Eyes Wide Open having
those conversations and just saying hey
what do you want do you want us to you
know to have something called an
advanced directive right which tells
doctors uh how much do you want to be
resuscitated you know do you want to be
um
help breathing do you want have help
having your heart beat right and so
those are documents that that actually
are medically necessary when you get to
the point of being in the hospital and
again we are all going to get to that
point if we're lucky to live long enough
and so um this is you know in in the
book we talk about an advanced directive
for driving right having a document that
says when do you want to uh turn turn in
your license right probably before
you're forced to do that by the
government I mean Myra talks about my
co-author talks about her mother
actually getting her license taken away
because she was driving so erratically
and was stopped by the police and we
don't you know want that to happen so
what are the signs right that that might
get you to that point it's much easier
to have that conversation in the
abstract than uh when it actually is uh
necessary
okay I mean let's bring this one home
why should people go if they want to
check out more of the stuff that you do
in the book
so we have a website moneylovebook.com
that has all sorts of places you could
buy the book we also have a quiz to uh
tell you what your money and love
decision making style is so we talked
about you know the analyzers there are
also two other styles and knowing your
type your tendency can help you put in
place uh some guard rails uh to to
overcome that tendency so that is a fun
thing that we offer on the website as
well all right Abby thank you thank you
so much what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]